the Sun Rosen for the green grass in
Ruby mushrooms birds sung the morning
song water trickled down the roof of the
houses many atones won't drown new
morning Mushroom Kingdom
warrior moves around the bed and tried
to keep the duvet on him and shut his
ears to the sound outside he itched his
butt and groans ah the debate flew up
from the bed and there's still Luigi
Luigi
he was fully dressed and not happy and
Mario Mario turned around at the bed he
was still on his red boxers Mario never
wore any pajamas either did Luigi yet
Luigi had been waiting for Moria to wake
up for ages Luigi tapped his fingers on
Mario's bedside clock oh how did we get
him over there it's only won a book okay
it's only one o'clock
Mario murdered Luigi wake me up at 8:00
they am Luigi rolled his eyes at Mario's
sleepiness it's a 1 p.m. move Luigi
shouted at Mario in the bed Morial
rolled out of the bed and put his finger
in his ears and wiped them clean 1 p.m.
only the [ __ ] why didn't you wake me up
Italian Mario was angry luigi growled at
him luigi tut it rolled his eyes like I
told you yesterday
I was out the read you turned around to
the bedroom door and walked out and
shutting the door on the way a sleepy
red brother tries to get up from the
bedroom floor with his eyes squinting
and looking around the room
what is it looking Oh bollocks beside to
himself Mario and Luigi are rushing down
the road to the castle their brothers
were laid to beach party this is all
your fault this is well I'm sorry
someone forget to wake me fire a replies
and his human brother I say both rush to
open the door of the prison princess
castle wish they already open everybody
inside looks at the late Mario and Luigi
when the end to everyone everyone is
just so what the [ __ ] was that coming
from Princess yelps at them across the
room yay
sorry we're late Beach everyone looks
back to peach waiting for another
applied to Mario statement the brothers
walk to voice of Princess and give them
their birthday presents for her don't
worry Mario kisses him on the cheek
Oh Luigi Luigi swayed his head to the
music whilst Mario was drinking the
brothers had had a lot of beer at the
time and they felt very drunk
their moms were not the usual self the
drunk brothers get up from the bar and
walk towards the exit they both felt
hammered and all they want to do was go
home and [ __ ] they walk down the road to
their own home they were drunk and
everything felt fuzzy hi I love you
Luigi Mario whispered to Luigi and then
he burps right into luigi space yeah
Luigi turned his head back to Mario and
bleach I love you too bro oh he puts his
arm round my shoulder and brings him
closer
which wraps Mario up and keeping him
warm
Mario kisses Luigi's arm
Mario kisses his brothers warm soft lips
those are Mario kisses brother on his
warm soft lips
Luigi blushes and the slight confusion
of what my artistic bluesy blushes and
his lips twitch wha-what was that for
yet once again he abruptly interrupted
again as Mario Jesus this time for
longer Luigi
instead of stopping Mario kisses his
brother back and then pushes Mario
against the wall kissing him
passionately perfect Mario accidentally
trips up on their living room sofa but
takes this opportunity and pulls his
brother closer they have been before you
sure you wanna [ __ ] is going on with
this fanfiction I'm so confused
how do they even kiss from this angle
they kiss more intimately and Mario
fills up his own brother's butt and
turns around pushing Luigi onto the sofa
what making making Mario on the top ok
good job
Brad iam are you that's a good boy hey
kid Mario Luigi kisses Mario's chest and
then does the same with his shirt oh
they throw their hats off and fill
through each other's hair whilst kissing
as Luigi sits on the edge of the sofa
watching Mario Luigi giggles at the
brother striptease ha ha
Mario is left standing in his Ruby
boxers he turned us around facing the
other way he then reveals his bare ass
to Luigi leaving the brother speechless
Maia slowly walks backwards to Luigi
and then turned slowly around to show
Luigi his own Lois 3ds jaw drops looking
at Mario's 5.9 inch
is that big I don't know inches
I guess it's the average size Luigi
slowly tries to touch Mario's come on
Mario eggs Luigi on touch it he puts his
glove hand on Mario's a Rick and his
other hand twiddles his fingers through
the mauryas pubic hair he cups down and
looks back up at Mario Luigi gulps down
he pulls out his tongue and circles it
around the head of his brother's car
Marius smiles at his brother and then
looks back at her for the roof 3d stops
the licking and opens up his jaw wide my
childhood is just going straight out
we know he childhood ruined
Luigi passes his mouth on tomorrow's car
making it warm yeah perfect he's looks
better that looks about like five point
nine inches daddy it's beautiful Mario
chefs brother as he feels his building
up oh yeah Mario working Luigi squirts
in winter Luigi Mario drops to the
ground moaning and groaning
Luigi slowly pulls down his underwear
which shows his six point is bigger than
Mario's he sways it back and forth
slapping Mario around the face
doggystyle
Luigi curiously asks his brother whilst
blushing even more thought if file more
applause Luigi and weeks back at him
Luigi gets on his all fours and crawls
towards his brother
it puts his arm over Mario's back and
then pulls his head towards Mario's ass
slowly pushes it in getting it deeper in
the two brothers give a soft groan my
mother me yeah Luigi pushes it in deeper
getting faster and faster
Mario groans louder so finally he slams
it in slapping Mario's ass with his ball
come on Luigi says to himself why still
[ __ ] his own brother thank you I
think we realized that now by now
Luigi suddenly stops as his seat squirts
right into Mario says he pulls out his
penis and lies on the floor okay this is
a beautiful moment
Luigi is broken
thank you Thank You Louie
haha